the FSL Surfer has been out of service
since the start of Yemen's War eight
years ago the oil tanker poses a grave
environmental threat to this region and
Beyond
decaying its structural Integrity has
been severely compromised
the large vessel contains more than a
million barrels of oil any incident
would be a disaster
Muhammad mudawi and his un team have
been working on a costly Salvage
operation to prevent the buildup of
flammable gases but mines litter the
area it is a very old vessel as you can
see a Decay vessel that is 47 years old
in the same location has not been
properly maintained over the last seven
years
so we had many concerns that it can
explode because of the gases it can also
break through a Dutch team is operating
a technical support vessel and ready to
step in in case oil leaks into the Red
Sea a spill would be a disaster it will
spread across the Red Sea extend to
bevelman Dev straight all the way to the
Gulf of Aden disrupting movement through
the Suez Canal and wiping out one of the
world's richest marine ecosystems
a spill would be four times the amount
of oil leaked into the sea in the 1989
axon Valdez accident
is the manager of the company that owns
the software now since the International
Community showed interest
it should be a complete solution for the
whole problem Pipeline and vessel and we
should complete the the surface storage
tanks that the Coalition stopped in the
coming days the oil on Border Sapphire
will be transferred to this vessel
Nautica Yemen but neither the houthis in
Sanaa nor the internationally recognized
government in Aden have yet to agree on
who owns the ship who has the right to
sell the oil once unloaded from the old
vessel
we want oil exports to resume and we
won't disagree over the 1 million
barrels oil is a world that belongs to
all of Yemen
for now workers make sure the oil tanks
are safe a potential spill could cost 20
billion dollars worth of environmental
damage and the Region's coral reefs will
need a quarter of a century to recover
off the coast of hadida Yemen